[Music]
welcome back y'all we got another
episode of not quite am I the [ __ ]
this is from our relationship advice and
it's more of Oh what would you do like
that couple corner couple corner so this
book it's it's a little it's a little
frazzled I think this comes from a guy
right after it happened and he's like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
so let's write after ejaculation right
yes he probably did come for clarity I
mean corner this one says I found condom
wrappers in our trash can my wife and I
don't use them I'm wondering how to
approach this oh he says I'm in a bit of
a difficult spot here and looking for
some advice earlier this week I was
taking the garbage out we have one of
those large 90 gallon wheeled trash cans
provided by the city and I noticed an
animal had gotten into it and one of the
bags had been torn open I also noticed a
couple of condom wrappers in there I had
a vasectomy a few years ago and my wife
and I don't use condoms this has led me
to wonder if my wife might be cheating I
realized this isn't damning evidence of
course and maybe there's possible
explanations as before now I've had no
reason to suspect my wife of infidelity
in the 10 years we've been married but I
also don't want to be the naive guy who
says oh it could never possibly happen
to me and ignores what's staring him
right in the face I'll try to organize
my thoughts a bit below there's a couple
of parts of this that make me suspect
her at least a little as I said I can't
think of anyone else in our house that
could have used them and throw them away
it's been a couple years since we last
used condoms but the wrappers I found
were her favorite kind when we were
using them we've had two preschoolers in
our sex life and intimacy in general has
been in a little bit of a rut so I'm
looking for advice on what should I do
next do I just assume it was someone
else throwing them away and just forget
about it do I stay quiet about it and
raise my alert level or do I go snooping
for a further evidence yeah this the
first thing he needs to do is accuse her
of being a [ __ ]
you know what I take a different
approach at least at least she's not
gonna get me STDs oh my god she's so
considerate you thanked her for being
safe thank you thank you if you're gonna
[ __ ] at least use a condom thank you
very much I'm so terrified of being
cheated on then like - I'm so like super
scared of it like what didn't you know
I'm sure I have I wouldn't know but you
didn't know nothing confirmed yeah well
I mean like pretty much yes because at
one point when I was in high school I
was dating a guy and he broke up with me
for another girl whom he started dating
like just a couple days after that saw
cheating there is probably some
emotional team they could have hooked up
to a lady in the room I think that was a
good guy who dumped you at the proper
moment and then he shot his shot after
that who's that's whatever but then he
was investing in her for like a year and
then oh yeah this one's a better one
yeah but nothing too bad nothing too bad
he didn't cross the cheaters or at least
when I've been cheated on like they
there's something and like you feel it
like there's like suspicious activity
and then you dig around and then you
find it and you're like well [ __ ] I knew
it
I'm never offended in your soul into my
soul and it's happened twice with two
long-term relationship it's felt in your
soul for two times yes and I like I go
crazy and I started hacking [ __ ] and
then I find [ __ ] but you know it's never
happened with this guy I've never ever
felt an inkling of needing to hack [ __ ]
or look at anything he's done so I feel
like I don't know maybe I don't know if
this guy's intuition is working very
well and it's nice I think it is he's
just hoping that it's not real in that
it sounds like what's her favorite
condoms it's in this and in that he
knows he doesn't want to believe been in
a rut she loves rainbow condoms rainbow
condoms our favorite yeah berry flavor
how about a huge shout out to the
[ __ ] coyote that ripped his trash
real real homing yeah like I see her
cheating
oh no this my human homie [ __ ] break
it open you know I'd be like listen cute
Han they're like oh no they dude
so when I was like Blackwell's yo when I
when I used to take the bus my bus
driver told us about how they would have
to beat on the side of the bus to get
all the raccoons out they open the door
and then beat the bus to get them out
cuz raccoons have these little tiny
hands and they could pull the bus door
open like crawl inside
so whenever the Bo I did they want to
get in the bus cuz it's hot more shelter
this is in Virginia between stops oh no
like at the bus line at the bus over
here we gonna sell like kids are in the
bus and that's also terrifying as a bus
driver because you get you get to your
bus six o'clock in the morning and you
see a little opening that you're like oh
[ __ ]
and if they had babies though they're
crazy they're not leaving that bus
they'll go fight you they try to like
fight you have you ever encountered that
mama mama raku no you could not get them
out of your house they just start think
start attacking you they'll such throws
you got a raccoon in your house I have
him but my boy always put in hi-c of a
sliding door and enjoy welcome back to
raccoon facts they'll take out a cat
eyeball records drink two liters of
water a day I worked at a cat shelter
and like a bunch of cats I had missing
eyes that's all raccoon fights did you
know that raccoons use napkins to clean
their mouths going back to this thing
though I think yeah his raccoon
man yeah I think so
when it comes down to cheating right
it's more it says more about the cheater
than the cheated where people feel the
cheated feel like they they're less than
or not worthy or they're not good enough
but in reality has nothing to do with
the person that's been cheated on has
everything to do with the cheater that
needs validation from another human
being or or they're just repetitive
offenders because no matter how much
they care about that person they still
need to it's like an addiction where
they need to be validated constantly
like Nicki had a friend who wanted
attention from men and she was married
and had kids and they were all in Vegas
together and she just wanted a dude to
[ __ ] hook up with because she wanted
to feel attention again instead of
voicing that at home to her husband like
this chicken sounds like should do like
or maybe she tried who the [ __ ] knows is
probably more of the story but it might
be like these people just take it among
themselves to take the initiation just
cheat and seven seconds initiation to
fix things right there low self-esteem
and they they have no hope that they can
relive that magic again in this union so
they they're like oh I just want that
like fresh new feeling you get it
whatever and then you're you don't think
that it can be supplied in that old
relationship or whatever it is but their
problem seems like the same problem
every relationship has where it seems
like neither of them are communicating
right like instead of him going like
talking to her about this but like hey I
found this feels like Internet what do I
do about these Condon communicates in
the point yeah if she can't communicate
about her like loneliness like you can't
yeah he can't communicate to her either
it's a common problem I've read
something one time that's really
interesting and also kind of made me sad
too I think it was about Elvis and there
was some interviewer and it could almost
a pedophile what look you'll say that
about Elvis but not Michael Jackson nope
which actually didn't marry a child Lisa
Marie Presley was like 14 right very
young yeah that's that's young right
well how young was the Michael Jackson's
accuser 8 but they weren't married I
heard they got married in his backyard
no no no evidence it said that Elvis
when he watched his mother his wife give
birth to their child his brain like a
switch flipped and she was no longer
this hot sexy woman yeah it's like now
that's the mother of my child and for
some men that's not like sexy anymore
dude for guys right so like if you're if
you're seeing someone and that you're
used to them looking a certain way and
then all of a sudden they turn the age
of 9 and they look a little bit
different you know if you've been taking
them to you to Neverland Ranch and now
they look 9 you're gonna find girl go
find a new girl you're gonna find a 7
year old who can dance like you and
every time and that's what I heard
Michael did to the kids and then he
cheated done on one of the dancer kids
with a younger dancer that's true that
was in the documentary yeah but there's
no evidence eeeh touchy subject there's
not like the parents and the that were
like validating all the stories in the
documents just as jealous no because the
actual evidence is they weren't there at
the time that they said they were but
you've got to get it right under those
kids age very similar stories from but
we're talking about this topic here
okay so what am i I'm so terrified being
cheated on
and I'm thought of this a thousand times
in my head and I don't know if I would
actually execute this but if I was being
cheated on I would have a conversation
with my significant other and this is
just what's going on my head right now
god forbid maybe in the moment I'm like
yeah this sounds scientific as hell I
know but I thought it was gonna be so
calm and rational no I was very nice
we'd be like dying inside but I would
ask them why did this happen like it
doesn't matter because it has nothing to
do with you but I mean it could be like
what if I'm not giving something what if
I'm not there for attention but also
they weren't exactly what people that
are the victim of cheating start
thinking that's everyone thinks that
they go what did I do wrong what did I
where was I it has my responsibility and
that's - yes it has nothing to do with
you if we had a kid and if I had a kid
and then Steve no longer saw me as sexy
I think I would have a conversation be
like yo you don't touch me the same and
I'm gonna I'm gonna go try to find
someone else have sex with the vetos
[ __ ] this is the first warning yo we
need to talk because unless this is
gonna be an open relationship I'm not
being sexually censorship I I will find
you a charger to the end of the earth
and that's right now so let's go around
the table artists you guys a question
if you got cheated on would you break up
say you're in a relationship three years
you're in three years if you got cheated
on would you break up with em yeah yeah
it depends on what kind of cheating you
trust anymore
you eat are always a cheaters because my
thing is is that okay this is gonna
sound really stupid but I've always been
like hopeless romantic once you're loved
and the way that I see technology
advancing and human minds and everything
I see open relationships being more
common in the future sure because what
do you look that
you I don't know okay I don't that's
what I thought too because I I think
that I think that there are different
types of sex I think that's just a sour
[ __ ] raw nasty means nothing sexual
with something that you're just sexually
attracted to nuts nothing which is
really not my thing but I understand
that that could happen with men but then
I understand there's that deep
passionate like you know relationship
sex and these things are so completely
separate I I want to believe because of
the environment I've been raisin that I
would be mad at that you know one night
and write a sex that's not you know
thank you for understanding that the
problem is breaking trust right if he
went up to you and you was like hey I
feel this way and I could have anything
if you agreed on an open relationship
right and it's not cheating
no no cheating is lying yeah and
basically omitting information and not
being clearly clearly honest and open
with everything but to to to what Moses
saying is though my thing that brings up
the concept of cheating and what
cheating is to each couple and
individual is different some people just
think flirting is cheating while others
are like well you can [ __ ] anyone you
want but if you fall in love with them
and [ __ ] them that's cheating yeah so
the each couple has to do have to make
their own rules of what is cheating
here's a really interesting example this
was a thing that came from twitch there
was a twitch couple that was dating and
they got outed the guy was cheating
through google docs but this was a long
calculated thing and he even so much
went to he even so much went to going on
google docs to hide this relationship
and was parading this woman around his
girlfriend for a month then there's also
a twitch streamer called doctor
disrespect who went to twitchcon meant a
[ __ ] vixen she's hot [ __ ] she was a
DJ she's like six feet tall like and he
[ __ ] her and it was like a Pat like a
heat in the moment like oh my [ __ ]
god and then two weeks later he kind of
gets like he gets blackmailed for it so
that's one thing do you [ __ ] her in
character he that would be so funny it's
blackmail for it but he feels so much
shame he comes clean to his wife he goes
on stream he says I [ __ ] up I need two
months off to the leader blackmailed him
or was going
I think it was somebody else that time
the video I doctor disrespected my wife
yeah that's what you said though but
it's like for like those are two
different types of cheating yes some
people it's close the book on both but
one of them's I'm like why did this
happen you know yeah but yeah sorry I
wait before we go I mean like I would I
think I would want to know why but at
the end I would I would leave it depends
on if kids are involved - mm-hmm I mean
that's true see the more older you
become the more it's complex it's not a
time to you I definitely would want to
know why but like if you cheat on me now
I'd be like get out got the house but so
you say until it's been done because you
have to be on both sides of the spectrum
to understand sure but if I had kids I'd
be more likely to want to make it work
what if it's a misunderstanding sure
though you bro you're a lot of talk
about this point oh